it's traumatic to be out here so if you
didn't have a trauma when you started
being homeless you do now as a result to
bang out here
I've been homeless for three years 12
years I've been homeless for close to a
year about three years six years this
pasture
Oh what's this gonna happen to anybody I
went to college had a career and I
wasn't supposed to be homeless I mean
I'm nervous I believe that when people
look at me as an example of the homeless
person they think that this could be
them and it truly could be I became
homeless due to my finances I lost my
job I lost my place that I was renting I
myself I've struggled with addiction I'm
proud to say I've been clean and sober
for six years I am a mechanic I studied
aviation maintenance I suffer from
depression also and I was
self-medicating with alcohol lost my job
and was he victim my back deteriorated I
could not work as much as I used to I
was in a domestic violence situation
that got worse and worse
truly the hardest thing is being
separated from your family and friends
when you're homeless you're pretty much
forgotten about I'm really lonely and
it's sucked you're really on the street
the hardest part is sleeping finding
somewhere to lay down it to really feel
safe or comfortable enough to go to
sleep you're treated like you're not a
full person you're treated like you're
like an animal and it's horrible the
hardest thing I found initially is
dealing with with people it's tough you
have to steel yourself against living in
a place with dozens of other people and
making sure that your basic needs are
met if you're sick you don't feel well
you don't have the privacy to be sick I
private your man at the system for not
providing you somewhere to sleep and
then and it really it really hits you
late you don't have nowhere to go it
gets sad that's what
drove me to make sure that I always have
a bed at the shelter because the shelter
isn't the most part the only thing
keeping me alive just remembering that
we're still people even despite our
homelessness is probably just about
enough to make several of our days just
sometimes it's stunning a hand or just
even saying good morning or just smile
at somebody as you go by can really make
a difference not everybody is a drunk
drug addict or someone that never worked
so just don't judge I think that's why a
lot of people talk to themselves just
because nobody talks to him I mean
sitting down and talking to the person
that makes their day when you approach
them with the conversation just opening
up a conversation with them it lights
them up like if you just came up and
gave him a hundred dollars